Pull up-eroni a cardboard pizza stool.
Right next to your portable, collapsible,
solar-powered Anywhere Fridge
Because episode 43 of LÜT......
Before heading out for the night cover yourself
deliciously with Pizza Cologne.
But be sure to put on a wearable safety device
in case it attracts any hungry bad guys.
First Sign creates headbands and hair clips
that detects movements of an attack, trigger
an alarm, and then automatically collect evidence
through a microphone.
Then check your LEDmeKnow Lightup Box that
blinks silent color-coded lights to let you
know who's trying to get ahold of you and
how without needing to check your phone.
You won't have to check the weather anymore
because the Smart Cloud brings the weather
to you in the form of a speaker and light.
Hopefully it rains enough to plant your own
pencils.
Or at least these pencil numbs nubs that have
hidden seeds inside to grow our own plants.
Plant yourself in front of a some Manga Shakespeare
and then use your Manga Cookbook to cook yourself
a Cat Burger....bed.
You've Cat To Be Kitten Me Right Now!
If a beloved pet passes away bring them back
as a tree with this Biodegradable Pet Urn
which holds the seed of your choice.
Watch movies, TV and plays video games anywhere
with this Keeker - the portable projector
that features 360 degree sound and then project
the time, messages, and your Facebook status
with this projection watch.
The Ritot displays a multitude of applications
onto your hand that you can dismiss with the
shake of your wrist.
And it's also waterproof.
Or you could just turn into an Instant Unicorn
that comes in this handy four pack.
Personally I don't need a horn to be legendary
because I Believe In Myself.......Pillow
Make others believe your books are floating
with this Hanging Book Rack or just hang out
in your amazing Floating Outdoor Bed.
Then sit by the fire and change the colors
with some Mystical Fire Colorants and hold
hands with a loved one online with Frebble.
A small handheld device that lets you use
Skype, FaceTime, or their own app to send
touch to people from far away.
If you don't have anyone to virtually hold
hands with use a Fidget Ring to play alone.
Each different design allows you to tilt,
roll, and slide parts around to keep your
hands busy if you need that.
Keep your hands and ears full with DubStein.
The mug integrates speakers so you have music
everywhere you put your beverage.
Like sitting atop this Shipping Container
Coffee Table.
For a drink that's challenging use this Crossword
Mug and hopefully you're good with words because
"I'm not sure how many problems I have because
math is one of them."
THE SWEATSHIRT!
If you have a problem knowing which end of
the towel to use this towel reminds you where
to put your face.
After all that my face is going straight into
a pillow because I already want to take a
nap tomorrow.
And as always, thanks for watching.